Adams shoes representative congressmen
made up what I said he actually took
words and made it up the reason is when
he saw my call to the president of
Ukraine it was so good that he couldn't
work them because there was nothing done
wrong it was perfect
so Adam Schiff decided I can't let this
happen so let me make up you ever hear
of this one gene you never hear with new
labels so Adam Schiff made up a phony
call and he read it to Congress and he
read it to the people of the United
States and it's a disgrace this whole
thing is a disgrace has been tremendous
corruption and we're seeking it
it's called drain the swamp there's been
corruption on the other side has been
corrupted like you've never seen now the
new president of Ukraine ran on the
basis of no corruption that's how he got
elected and I believe that he really
leads but there was a lot of corruption
having to do with the 2016 election
against us and we want to get to the
bottom of it and it's very important
that we do thank you